mais de quoi va-t-on parler aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va parler de maison
connectée on veut parler de praticité
parce que vous le savez j'aime bien vous
rendre service et je vous présente
notamment des engins pour la maison des
objets connectés plus intelligente pour
dire vous faciliter le quotidien
et aujourd'hui je vous parlais de ce
produit là une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec eco vague parce que les
kovac saigne barroso mais monsieur si tu
nous parlais aujourd'hui d'autres
nouveaux robots aspirateurs dont le nom
est marc est juste là dit bottes aux
mots 920 qu'est ce que vient faire ce
yvonne osmo 920 en quoi est-ce qu'il va
venir vous solutionner la vie et surtout
est ce qu'il est intéressant
alors je vous le dis tout de suite nous
annonce la couleur déjà ce robot est à
gagner je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description il ya un concours
pour venir à gagner vous votre robot qui
aidera vous nettoyez votre maison et
vous solutionner la vie très facilement
donc c'est très très cool et le deuxième
point c'est là en ce moment il un tarif
qui est vraiment hyper intéressant à 275
euros 11 faut savoir qu'à la base il
coûte 419 euros mais qu'en ce moment
vous le savez c'est la fête des prix il
ya plein de promo j'explique tout ça en
fin de vidéo
en tout cas si vous intéresse vous a mis
un lien en bas dans la description si
vous et les robots aspirateurs ça fait
quinze qui vous expliquer comment ça se
passe vous avez un petit robot
aspirateur
l'avant est ici l'arrière est ici
lorsqu'il va venir avancée qui va
trouver un objet qu'est ce qui va se
passer
eh bien il va venir le toucher savoir
s'enfoncent un peu de vent il va se
décaler il va bouger
ici en haut là juste là à l'intérieur il
un petit laser qui permet de
cartographier votre maison je me sens
dans l'application dans quelques
instants
posez votre bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre et à l'intérieur vous avez un
petit bac qui va venir accueillir la
poussière dans celui là vous avez en
plus un petit bouton qui est planqué
juste là pour venir l'activer et le
désactiver ici une petite brosse est
pour venir nettoyer puis pour couper
tous les petits fils indélicats qui
voudraient vous embêter à l'arrière un
réservoir d'eau parce que oui ça nettoie
ses pratiques qui va pouvoir venir en
plus nettoyer votre sol et en plus de ça
vous avez ici ce qui va faire office de
serpillière qui va venir nettoyer votre
sol extrêmement facilement donc vous
laissez votre bac ou pas au et ensuite
vous passiez votre petit saint-pierre
sur le dessous vous avez cette petite
brosse rotative donc là ça va venir
aspirer tourner en même temps ils vont
ramasser toutes vos cochonneries et là
vous avez deux petites brosses latérales
qui vont venir
mais les cochonneries par ici pour
qu'elles soient inspirées c'est très
pratique en plus et toute une flopée de
capteurs retrouvez ici ici et deux sur
l'avant qui vont être des capteurs pour
voir s'il est dans le vide oui oui enfin
je vous explique ça
[Musique]
moi j'ai utilisé des robots aspirateurs
depuis déjà quelques temps et je trouve
ça vraiment mais vraiment très très très
très pratique parce que ça vient
vraiment vous faire gagner du temps
alors ça c'est dingue parce qu'à la base
pas forcément ose dire tout aussi joli
mot juste un petit robot aspirateur et
croyez moi le temps gagné il est assez
dingue on met ça c'est vraiment
extrêmement coûteux alors en plus
intérieure vous avez de quoi changer
votre fils vous avez de quoi changer vos
petits bouts rosell parce que oui à
force ça finit par s'user
donc ça c'est bien et vous êtes vraiment
tranquille et vous avez même des petite
lingette que vous allez venir poser
juste en dessous ici lorsque vous allez
dire nettoyer votre sol vous le savez je
vous apprends rien ici on est une chaîne
de teck donc si je vous parle d'un
produit comme celui là pour la maison
c'est que c'est un produit qui est bardé
de technologies et qui en plus de vous
rendre des services pour votre intérieur
acquis non négligeable parce que moi je
déteste passer l'aspirateur mais
vraiment je déteste vraiment passer
l'aspirateur
ça me permet de me dégager un stand by
pour faire autre chose tout en ayant de
maison propre et ça c'est très bien
eh bien vous avez beaucoup de capteurs
vous avez en robot qui au final assez
intelligent
je vous passe un peu le b à ba il vient
aspirer il vient nettoyer nettoyer si
vous lui mettez de l'eau intérieur vous
pouvez tout régler vous avez des
capteurs il a un laser et en plus il est
silencieux plutôt bien grâce à ses
capteurs et à pouvoir connaître s'il est
sur un sol dur ou sur un tapis pour
adapter l'aspiration y aspirer encore
plus sur un tapis grâce à son laser et
dernière cartographie et votre maison
pour savoir quelles sont les pièces
quels sont les espaces ça vous permettra
dans un premier temps d'aller l'envoyer
vers une pièce en particulier si vous ne
souhaitez le faire mais je le montre
dans l'appli dans quelques instants
mais ça vous permettra surtout de savoir
où il est passé où il n'est pas passé
dans quelle zone et pouvoir surveiller
l'aspiration de votre maison point qui
est pratique il est tout petit a fait
face à lui permet de se glisser en
dessous de vos meubles en dessous de
votre lit pour venir tout nettoyer très
facilement et vous enlevez les éventuels
moutons qui pourraient traîner sous
votre lit c'est pas terrible et moutons
souligne patron comme il est malin il
peut passer au dessus des obstacles
jusqu'à 2 cm je pense notamment aux
seuils de portes
il détecte les obstacles les escaliers
et surtout vous pouvez piloter grâce à
notamment amazon avec ça et notamment
google assistant mais surtout c'était
plus intéressant et 6 et ce qu'il a
vraiment venir nous intéresser c'est la
collectivité voir de quelle manière vous
arrivez à le piloter depuis votre
smartphone et notamment à le programmer
pour que l'aspiration deviennent
complètement invisible pour vous si ce
n'est vider votre bac de poussière ou
remplir un mcdo le reste vous ne vous en
occupez tout se passe ici dans mon
application et kovacs home dans laquelle
je veux retrouver mon robot aspirateur
j'ai quelques infos essentielles le nom
du robot je suis en mode sa pierre pour
l'instant il est en pause j'ai dit
absolument rien nettoyer pas vu parce
que forcément là je vous faisais un
petit est l'appli est pas fonctionnel
je vous explique comment ça marche
première chose que vous voyez en bas
c'est un bouton pour venir lancer le
nettoyage alors là il est juste là donc
c'est un petit peu dommage j'avais tout
de suite l'arrêter voilà on a mis la
pause juste à gauche ici d'une petite
icône qui va m'intéresser qui me servira
à avoir deux zones une limite virtuel
c'est un mur virtuel pour lui dire tu ne
vas pas tel endroit et des zones à ne
pas laver vous allez pouvoir grâce à
votre laser je le dis finir
cartographier votre intérieur et une
fête la cartographie et faites-vous lui
dit tu ne vas pas l'abbé cette zone par
exemple un endroit où j'aurai les jeux
d'elliot je peux pas qui les inspirent
et où l'entrée de la chambre d'elliot
basque intérieur il ya plein de cartes
pokémon et de l'ego et que forcément
c'est pas une bonne idée qui direct mais
là où s'élevait le plus intéressant
c'est le menu que vous avez ici là je
suis en mode avancé ce mode avancé une
servira à venir
notamment enregistré la cartographie
grâce à la carte george est pas mal de
choses que ce soit ni régler notamment
la puissance d'aspiration standard max
les moonlight vous servir à lorsque vous
allez notamment recevoir des amis
voulaient faire un gros ménage devant
hong kong et bien venir nettoyer en
profondeur je peux ni règle est
également mon débit d'eau en fonction
des besoins que j'ai pour venir nettoyer
mon sol aspirations de la puissance
automatique moi j'ai les cernes
automatique matin prévient la règle et
comme vous le souhaitez le nettoyage
continuent activer/désactiver qui vous
servira que lorsque votre robot n'a plus
de batterie eh bien il a eu à se
recharger dans ce qu'il ait continué son
nettoyage ne pas déranger je veux par
exemple qui se mettent pas aspirer entre
21 heures et 9 heures oui la nuit je
dors c'est beaucoup mieux mais je peux
également venir lui dire de programmer
un nettoyage
alors je n'ai pas fait je peux lire par
exemple programmé à nettoyage
automatique je veux que par exemple tu
arrives et nettoyer à 14h24 tous les
lundis tous les mardis tous les
mercredis pour te sois toujours propre
et de la même manière je peux l'envoyer
vers un nettoyage de zone en lui disant
tu vas me nettoyer ma chambre tel jour à
la salle de bains tel jour la cuisine
tous les jours comme ça j'ai un
nettoyage c'est toujours optimisée
j'ai ensuite accès à mon journal de
nettoyage ceux notamment qui s'il m'a
fait 51 mètres carrés pendant 76 minutes
et je vois très exactement où est ce
qu'il est passé combien de fois et de
quelle manière le nettoyage a été fait
et voyez ce qui est très bien c'est
qu'il est même passé ici sous mon lit ça
c'est très cool plus de moutons au
revoir les moutons merci beaucoup mais
je vois également l'utilisation des
accessoires brosses latérales 98% bronze
principal 99% et le filtre à 90% comme
ça je vois exactement quand est-ce qu'il
est temps de les changer et je peux me
retrouver mon robot si jamais j'ai perdu
il ya notre temps qui est extrêmement
pratique c'est que si vous avez un
appartement à plusieurs étages ou une
maison à étage ou un château vous voulez
et bien vous allez pouvoir cartographier
chaque étage indépendamment il va
connaître les pièces et va donc venir
enregistrer vos différentes cartes
extrêmement facilement
comme vos pièces ont enregistré vous
pouvez même définir un ordre de
nettoyage commence par la cuisine la
salle à manger ensuite la salle de bains
et les wc et puis finit par la chambre
bon faites comme vous voulez chacun fait
comme il veut chez soi et c'est un
produit vous trouvez un tarif vraiment
très intéressant je vous ai mis un lien
dans la description pour les trouver sur
le site d'amazon regarder normalement il
coûte 419 euros 98 tu l'as déjà ils vous
ont fait une remise à 400 en euros ont
été plutôt pas mal et en plus vous avez
un code coupon une remise de 50 euros en
plus ce qui appliqué mais ça ne s'arrête
pas là parce que regarder il vous avez
un message promotionnel avec un type de
remplacement qui coûte 39 euros 99 qui
vous est offert donc vous ajouter au
panier votre aspirateur plus votre kit
de remplacement vous cliquez sur passer
la commande
et là vous passez de 459 euros 97 entre
l'aspirateur et le kid de remplacement
vous arrivez à 351 euros 11 et en plus
avec un code promotionnel que vous venez
saisir je voulais marquer en bas dans la
description
allez jeter un coup d'oeil ça vous
ramène le tout à 275 euros 11
autant vous dire qu'ici si vous voulez
acheter un bel aspirateur robot l'offre
elle est quand même extrêmement
intéressant avec ledit bottes aux mots
920 d'ecomax vous avez un aspirateur qui
est cool qui passera par toucher vous
qui vous solutionnera votre quotidien et
qui fera le tas pour vous dégrossir la
maison moi j'aime bien ces catégories
d'objets intelligents pour la maison
parce qu'effectivement ils nous font
gagner du temps et ça malgré tout ça
reste vraiment bien pour avoir une vie
zen et surtout à ce tarif là avoue le
médiamat temps vous ce que vous en
pensez en bar commentaire on se retrouve
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer à
parler de tête parce qu'à plein de
choses qui arrivent de tous les côtés
pour c'est la folie à très bientôt
beaucoup d'amour et des bisous tient
qu'à
[Musique]